You are listening to radio lab radio
from W. N y.
S. C. E. N. N. P. R. I'm Robert Krulwich. This is Radiolab, the podcast.
And today we are going to talk about global warfare
[inaudible] the hast back
across the planet on a scale that it's really hard to believe involving
trillions of deaths.
And yet
we really need this war because without it I wouldn't be here.
You wouldn't be here. Jad wouldn't be here.
And you may have noticed he isn't here and it's not because of awards cause he
had a baby. But before jab went on paternity leave, we sat down with Ari.
Daniel Shapiro. Okay. And he told us this story here at candles, right? Yes.
So he ran it, the center for the culture of Milian Phytoplankton.
And I always say Lee Wilson. Willie Wilson is his name. Yeah, that's tough.
Just like his grandfather actually.
Yeah. My Dad's William Wilson that are from a long line of William Wilson's.
Your son. I saw this Angus, but he's Angus. William Wilson.
So I that Guy Willie
works at the big laboratory for ocean sciences in Maine. Okay.
Any studies for these?
Tiny plant like creatures that live in the sea called phytoplankton.
He keeps them in a fridge in these little test tubes,
half full of kind of the greenish water, but then we'll look at that.
He pulled one out and showed it to me and it doesn't really look like there's
that much going on in there,
but actually right at the bottom you can see what looks like a,
like a white a,
what is it? It's the carnage of war in that test too,
that willys holding are millions of tiny single celled plants called Kaka Litho
fours Kako Kaka Litho fours. Yeah,
and there are lots of them in the sea.
There's probably about a hundred thousand of these coklat the force in a
teaspoon of sea water. Tell me about the Kochler, like what do they look like?
Basically like a like tiny little translucent balls with know a slight tinge of
green. But the key thing is that the outside of that bile is it has these white
plates,
tiny circular shields of chalk because the Kaka Litho fours are fighting for
their lives.
Yes, fighting with each other viruses.
These viruses that are shaped like diamonds.
So here's what happens. Imagine your Akaka Litho for, okay.
Floating in the ocean and along comes this diamond shaped virus and it jams it's
diamond tip into you
between these plates and actually get inside the cell, the chinks in the armor.
That's right. It's like the chinks in the armor
and the coccoliths Litho for
just Goldson and the virus things. Yes, I'm in here.
And then it sort of mix straight to the nucleus
and it's at that moment that the viral takeover begins.
The virus kind of hijacks the cellular machinery.
That's usually used by the [inaudible]
let the four to make more coccoliths for stuff and it starts making more
viruses.
So inside the cochlear for now there are these little diamonds multiplying.
Yeah.
They're filling up that space and eventually all these viruses head out of the
cockle at the floor in big belches or like a steady stream of viruses.
Wow.
And each one of these bonuses has the ability to,
to go on and then fact another coccoliths are for sale.
In fact, those coccoliths fours in that test too, that willy showed me my shake.
This just stuck to the of them a little bit. Yeah.
Those were in the process of dying.
Smell that. Yeah. So that what you're smelling now that's, that's the infection.
That's dimethyl sulfide as well.
So then faction is already occurring in this culture
and when the coccoliths Litho Ford dies,
those white shields kind of fall off.
They sort of gradually sort of reign off over the course of the infection.
So as it's dying, after it's spewed out, these viruses,
it just sheds its plate and it kind of, and then it dies.
Yeah. And that creates this white chalkiness. Yeah. Well,
so this means like the Coco Litho boys are not doing very well. Oh, well.
They've got a couple of tricks up their little calcified sleeves.
Sometimes when a virus enters the cockle, let the four,
we'll send out a chemical signal. There's saw shouting, hey,
it's too late for me, but save yourselves.
And initially this signal's pretty weak in the water,
but as more and more coccoliths fours are infected,
the chorus of this chemical beacon grows louder and louder.
And so the other cells that hear these messages
and they change by messing with their DNA a bit,
and they go from having those white shields on the outside to having these
jaggedy scales,
which we think might be in pen of stubble scales instead of these plates, right?
Yep. Yeah. The site. Why aren't they just scaly all the time?
Because when they're scaly,
they can't be the best cockle with the fours they can be,
they just don't grow as well. So scaly is an adaptation against the viruses.
Exactly. And then finally, if all else fails,
program cell death,
the Kaka Litho fours just commit suicide just shuts down and kills itself to
prevent propagation of viruses. But over time,
the viruses have figured out how to prevent the sale from killing themselves.
So it delays the death of the coccoliths [inaudible] for long as possible
to maximize the number of viruses that can get out. Wow.
This is serious. Yeah, it's like an arms race. There's a constant battle
too, to be fitter than you were several generations ago. And with those,
here's the crazy thing,
this battle is happening all through the surface. Yeah.
The ocean, there are legions of coccoliths,
Litho forest dying all the time and the Kaka Litho forests are shedding their
white shields,
like taken millions of tiny little midos and putting them in the surface of the
ocean.
So many that you can actually see this carnage from space.
[inaudible]
you can see this from space. Yeah. You get, um,
massive blooms that cover almost the whole of the North Atlantic.
I mean you get this sort of milky bloom that covers anything from,
you know,
off the west coast of Scotland and their southern Iceland almost all the way to
Newfoundland. I'm in the southern hemisphere.
You get this sort of massive milkiness that circumnavigates the globe,
these vast swirls of milky water curling around islands and continents and
that's all carnage from this battle.
Billions and billions of soldiers that have fallen in the field. Wow.
That we can view from space.
It probably is trillions if you're talking on that scale. Yeah.
I think that the trillions quadrillion.
Do you think and you think it's wearing the quadrillions, just say it.
See how it feels. There are quadrillions of soldiers dying.
How did that feel? It felt good.
If I were to be an astronaut,
how often would I see these sorts of blooms all the time.
Somewhere on the planet. Every day, every hour,
the every hour. Those there's going to be a bloom going on somewhere. You know,
a good example is off the Norwegian fjords.
They stopped in the fjords and late April into may time and then they sort of
creep to the fjords like this huge living a Amoeba.
Fishermen hate it because the fish can't see the, the lure,
so they can't catch the fish anymore
and as the shields rain off and fall down to the ocean floor,
they build up and build up over time.
Millions of years of sedimentation of these sort of chalk particles.
That's actually what led to the creation of the cliffs of Dover.
The white cliffs of Dover in England shut up. Really? Yes.
This is geology and action. And not just that, when the coccoliths,
the fours get decimated by the virus,
it kind of clears out the ocean for other phytoplankton to bloom.
And then they get mowed down by their viruses.
And then the Kaka Litho fores might bloom again and then they get wiped out.
And this cycle with all these bottles that mean that it's all responsible for
about half the, the oxygen that we breathe.
Really half the oxygen,
we breathe half the oxygen because when the phytoplankton bloom,
they take in carbon dioxide and they release a puff of oxygen
[inaudible]
and then they're cut down by these viruses,
but they grow back up again.
Wow.
And another breath is released.
So the whole system is, is just kind of breathing
[inaudible]
people think of the, the lungs of the planet, uh, are the,
the rainforests. And that's, that's kind of half the picture.
But every other breath we take comes from the, the phytoplankton.
The notion that had gone through these battles on a, you know, on a daily basis.
So this is a battle that rages every single day somewhere in our oceans.
Yeah. We need the battle to live.
[inaudible]
Ari, thank you. Sure.